azerbaijan's Ministry of Defense says
this video shows strikes against
Armenian saboteurs operating inside
azerbaijan's territory
days of fighting around the Border
region close to nagorno-karabakh has
killed more than a hundred Armenian and
70 aziri soldiers
both sides accuse each other as starting
the fighting Azerbaijan says it was
responding to the Armenian Army's
shelling of aziri military positions
The Armenian defense Ministry released
this video it says shows aziri soldiers
moving into Armenian territory Al
Jazeera cannot independently verify
footage released by either side
anger fled in the Armenian Capital
Yerevan overnight with protesters
demanding prime minister Nicole
pashinyan resign
the demonstration started after
pashinyan implied a peace deal had been
signed with Azerbaijan he denied the
claim antarope is Washington cup I
officially stated no paper has been
signed moreover no paper is going to be
signed and there is no talk about any
paper this information is a conspiracy
to demoralize our soldiers standing at
the border
Russia has tried to maintain relations
with both countries and on Tuesday
trying to broker a ceasefire but the
fighting continued
Azerbaijan does not see Russia as an
honest broker and there are fears
another full-blown War would risk
dragging in azerbaijan's most powerful
Ally turkey the collecting security
Treaty Organization are meeting at the
request of Armenia where yarowan is
seeking this uh de-escalation to the
situation between the two countries this
is of course both institutionally
problematic and also many would say
biased since Azerbaijan is not a member
of the russian-led collective security
Treaty Organization
Armenia announced a new ceasefire took
effect on Wednesday night but there has
been no official comment from Azerbaijan
on an agreed truce at a time of great
uncertainty over the war in Ukraine this
latest upsurge in fighting between two
more post-soviet States is of great
concern to neighboring countries and
those struggling amidst the energy
crisis
the latest fighting along the borders
and close to nagorno-karabakh show that
despite the 2020 peace initiative
finding a lasting political solution to
this crisis one that has huge
geostrategic implications is nowhere in
sight Charles Trafford Al Jazeera Baku